Nick sartora is a video journalist who
is on the ground there in East Palestine
Ohio he's spoken to business owners and
residents of the town he joins us now
Nick thank you so much for coming on
um
makes me feel bad we're not there that
that you are what's your assessment of
the town right now
so what's going on on the ground is is a
little bit different from what you might
see in the media uh the sentiment from
the resident seems to be that they are
super annoyed at how the federal
government how the Biden Administration
in particular is handling this situation
you have the EPA in particular they
won't talk to any of the residents you
have people that are right up there I
spoke with a a a a small business owner
that was uh their business was right in
front of where the explosion was they
can't get anything out of the EPA the
federal government came in for a few
days took over their entire business
would not let them in okay but also
wouldn't talk to them and wouldn't give
them a plan wouldn't tell them anything
and that's exactly how it's going for
everybody that's in this town so they
don't know if they're going to be
abandoned by the federal government and
and they don't know if their town is
going to be wiped off the map and it's
it's really sad when you're talking to
these people because they are terrified
that this town that they grew up in that
they've lived in for their entire lives
is going to be a completely
demolished by people having to leave
people scared to even come back to the
town there there's a myriad of people
that do not believe the epa's assessment
that the town is okay to go back into so
they just haven't bothered and that is a
really scary thing to think that the
federal government cannot be trusted
enough to be able to tell us whether or
not it's safe to go in an area like this
well they forced the coveted vaccines in
the country so I think they can't be
trusted but I'm as interested as a
factual matter
is the EPA tracking where this cloud of
chemicals went I mean it it was a local
problem it became a regional problem do
we have any information on the effects
of of those clouds of chemicals
yeah so Tucker the EPA is not releasing
a lot of the data that that they've
supposedly been collecting they were
supposed to release data last week on
water samples right how was the water
supply uh contaminated was groundwater
contaminated they have not done any of
that okay that's another thing that
residents are are complaining about a
lot because they don't even know if they
can trust their own uh tap water they
don't want to turn on their Taps a lot
of these people do have wells but they
have no clue if their groundwater has
been contaminated
this is America this is a first world
country I mean
yeah or was Nick shelter I sure
appreciate that report from the scene in
East Palestine Ohio thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight